like my Hardy yep
Rob boundary oh hey you went up north to
see head of five forge mode mm-hmm the
embargoes dance now we can talk about it
yeah tell me why I should be interested
in halo 5 forge mode Mike McCarty well
it's come to PC now as the personal
computer I have one of those yes yeah on
a September 8th that's the night i play
my winamp songs yeah 9 though we're what
when I'm okay really whips the llamas
ass remember that sorry continue a
pillow fight virus thing
no yeah halo 5 forge mode is coming to
PC now with Windows 10
it's a ninth update ninth DLC Anvil's
legacy they've been pretty constantly
just kind of revitalizing halo 5 since
last year October this one is pretty
interesting because forged obviously
previously has just been consigned to
controller input right rod-like xbox one
xbox 360 controller scheme so your mass
keyboard in this stuff yeah so now you
can you know click and drag things as
opposed to like tapping on it and moving
your analog you can you can just
manually like change the trajectory of a
man can and you can you can type in like
specific mathematical like numbers like
if you want the man cannons angle to be
like 45 point three five zero degrees
you could do that whatever cool opposed
to liking the scale and slowly which
time and yeah for a mode that is so
heavily on like I need to do this
quickly because time is of the essence
does it give you more precision then as
well it's imagine like a shooter playing
she's playing a shooter on a controller
as opposed to a mouse and keyboard
except like 10 times more easily now so
is there anything else that I'm just
thinking about like PC implants over
consoles so is there like is there more
scaled can use more assets in the levels
and it'll like that um I don't know
whether they I don't think there's any
more like like memory capacity or
anything right and for the reason being
that they still want you I mean you know
you're limited on PC but the idea is
that you're still creating maps for the
Xbox right ok you can't you know exceed
any limit that the Xbox can't handle
yeah but you can also test these the
match you're creating on PC so you
essentially can just play custom games
on PC with mouse and keyboard which we
did we played probably like an hour's
worth or so
a couple of rounds I mean that's so wild
is that this is like Halo 5 on PC you
can write you know you can play with
friends - like matchmaking campaign for
free so yeah so how many people can you
get in there just - it's no custom game
is ov8 right sure ok I think it's not
big team battle so it's ap 8 right you
guys don't don't like quote me on that
but that's like the typical okay so this
is 44 8vh right this is like a tool
that's been set up to basically try and
get more Maps perhaps and like Halo 5 in
the on the Xbox one version but like you
can just straight-up download this make
a bunch of apps and just play them with
your friends can you can you can you
import Maps the other that are on the
Xbox one version or a play on the stuff
that you've made yourself right you can
go back and forth so it's it's very much
a cross-platform interface and like what
was really exciting to was you know for
someone who you know I enjoy making maps
but like it very intimidating it takes a
while on the Xbox one now they have kind
of revamped their whole UI for a forge
allowing for featured Maps yet seen
because you know at the other day it's
like okay I created a map in you know in
Forge what now what do I do with it
where is it gonna go how do I share it
sure enough you can you know like in
favor it you can it's got a bunch of a
revamp and keywords so I can find maps
easier it's a really nuanced search
filter you can take out like the person
the user's name like if you played a map
by like Turco Bango or yeah it can be
like okay I like his this map let me
check out his other maps you can say
like I want this tile set I want this
kind of like people will like can
categorize it per game oh that's really
well like SWAT or whatever and the most
exciting thing is they have they've
pushed their prefabs which is
essentially like I can make a building I
can make anything in forge I can group
them all and then I can just send that
to the web in that you can just take
that Oaks alright really awesome and I
think this is just gonna expedite all
the cool map so you see because there
are some really great ones a lot of Star
Wars maps and stuff podracing someone
like takes a ghost yeah and is able to
put like the engines you know if like
Anakin's podracers yeah so what's really
cool is like essentially I could
that guy's all of his podracers hmm just
bring them in save me hours and hours of
time now all I can do is just make maps
right and make my own
podracing map have they talked at all
about how like you for instance if you
typed in like a Mario into this like
will that stuff appear hell yeah I think
their tether tags yeah yeah you can just
search that say like I don't know if to
reference like an old-school map if
you're playing like Blood Gulch yes if
you do that kind of tile set and you
don't want to take the time to design
the entire blue team's base of entire
red team's you just search like capture
the flag base and it'll bring up the
preset like how about 3540 items that
someone combined already and just place
those all on the map it's really cool I
mean and you're doing that like in your
own map right so you're not like exiting
your map and like highlight you just do
it in game just like old me search BAM
drop it ace drop it in and it's quick
and that's guys pretty cool so hopefully
I'll start them you know people do that
whole thing where they remake every
other you know won a tournament in quake
level and yeah let's take it in there
it's always part of like a wider effort
I guess to bring more I mean like
there's a lot of Xbox games gonna be on
Windows 10 as well right but they've set
halo 6 will be on Windows 10 they
haven't confirmed whether they're gonna
port halo 5 to Windows 10 although like
we said there's it seems like a matter
of time like because you know
matchmaking forges on there you know
many perhaps maybe that's it or maybe
they're doing it the opposite way where
they're they're going to just lay the
groundwork here so that when halo 6
comes out that maybe like all this stuff
works there as well or like a similar
sort of system and the Windows 10 app
the Halo app is also like a hub for
trailer as well as that's where you're
gonna play Halo Wars 2 through halo TV
yeah all there yeah like although like
the miniseries Unforgiven yeah good
stuff interesting yeah super interesting
almost like a free version of Halo 1 PC
and it felt good with Mouse and people
were like you know we were talking like
we play it's SWAT which was you know
headshots kind of lonely and yeah yeah
it was fun course yeah PCB that's more
fun it's great I mean if you are the
kind of person who plays play like old
halos just to play custom games like
land parties your friend yeah you can do
that for free right now with 5 that's
excellent
good something when is this September
8th ok yeah Anvil's legacy is the name
of that deal
pack and villes legacy there are new
racket items as well
rec items items acquisition if you play
hilly there's packs that you call a new
weapons with sick of super mag also
features new rec packs check him at